c'était prévu dans l'accord de nouméa
signé il y à déjà plus de vingt ans
qu'un accès caldoches doivent dire oui
ou non à l'indépendance de la nouvelle
calédonie chez nous l'événement est
suivi de très près par les différentes
composantes de l'échiquier politique
à commencer par les militants
anticolonialistes de la première heure
plutôt sceptique
tout le monde sait que de toute façon le
résultat sera dans les dépendances et en
grande majorité
pourquoi parce que l'état français
coloniale guettier les moyens
médiatiques
il détient des moyens financiers il ya
possibilité de faire chantage à l'emploi
dans les entreprises grip control et
donc on ne sait ce ne sont pas des
conditions valable de l'exercice du
droit à l'autodétermination
c'est vrai que ça se passait son côté
que c'est extrêmement difficile
en tout cas pour les peuples comme le
nôtre et dynamique elle c'est une
expérience à suivre avec avec attention
et non pas pour copier les choses
animatiques parce que chaque pays a sa
propre dynamique mais pour voir comment
et les les problématiques de libération
peuvent se poser dans le contexte qui
est le nôtre journée absent du débat le
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
le mime fait savoir qu'il ne souhaite
pas réagir à cette actualité
de leur côté les autonomistes observe ce
scrutin avec la plus grande attention
notre détermination de tous les peuples
y compris la marne l'aube c'est un droit
inaliénable et imprescriptible à ce
titre là je pense qu'on a fait déjà des
choix le premier choix 146 mais un
deuxième choix qui a été fait quitter
pas un changement statutaire
extrêmement important mais de fait
d'avoir une collectivité unique à la
place de deux collectivités
c'est un processus de réorganisation de
rationalisation des politiques publiques
et puis demain cet allemand il peut
avoir aussi des avancées sur le plan
purement institutionnels quant à
l'incident sur nos populations outre-mer
nos populations antillaises
j'en veux dire que ça va ça va jouer ça
va pas jouer parce que compte tenu de ce
qui se passe entre l'outre-mer et le
gouvernement français si effectivement
le we passe en nouvelle calédonie ça va
certainement donner des idées à nos
populations
à droite ce référendum ne laisse
également pas indifférent même si on
estime chez les républicains que
comparaison n'est pas raison on comprend
bien que la nouvelle calédonie ce n'est
pas la martinique on et ça s'entend bien
si les martiniquais là toutes les
élections qui se sont déroulées
on voit que les martiniquais ont
vraiment systématiquement rejetées en
bloc toute idée de séparation avec la
france alors peut être quelque chose il
y aura peut-être une évolution
après ce sera aux gens partisans de
cette évolution de convaincre la
population
les résultats du référendum devrait
tomber dès dimanche midi chez nous
compte tenu des 16 heures de décalage
horaire avec la nouvelle calédonie